by keeping fit and healthy is important
to many of us but there's a new warning
that crash exercise fitness trends are
leading to a record number of under-30s
needing hip replacements its claims that
a rise in popularity of high-impact
training designed to achieve results as
quickly as possible has led to an
increase in illnesses among young people
that are more traditionally associated
with the over-50s so can exercise
actually do more harm than good joining
me now to talk about this of the health
of fitness expert Neil Dimmick and
physiotherapist and triathlete daniel
boyd very good morning to you both neo
demic let's start with you hear people
just taking exercise too far people
under 30 needing hip replacement seems
crazy well I think it depends it depends
how you're exercising you we need to we
need to take exercise obviously we all
of us need to take exercise I think that
we are as general an unfit nation we
need to take regular exercise but I
really think it depends what kind of
exercise that you're doing and how
you'll being taught more importantly
daniel boyd you're a physiotherapist as
well as being a triathlete do you think
people go into this kind of high
intensity training kind of blindly not
realizing the impact it can have on
their body what kind of injuries are you
seeing as a result of this well I do see
an increase in sort of impact injuries
and people taking up support for the
first time and then developing sort of
overuse injuries quite quickly because
they're not conditioned to the type of
sport that there then trying to get into
particulars or your high intensity and
very quick high-impact exercises that
you substantially more nowadays as a
triathlete have you seen I've seen it
around where I live at a huge boost in
the number of people offering kind of
high-intensity sessions boot camps you
know they're kind of all over the place
aren't they people do it when they're
perhaps not used to that level of
exercise because they want to lose
weight and they want to get fit quickly
we haven't kind of got the patience to
kind of spend hours and hours at the gym
anymore yeah I mean it's great that
firstly the people are doing exercising
as Neil says the donation is getting
bitter and sort of sort of intuitively
more active but yeah I think progression
is key and the technique and the right
guidance from the professionals are out
there and became more more readily
available
information is is rife and quite
accessible nowadays for people to sort
of educate themselves and how they
should be doing things and Daniel do you
think people take the time to actually
educate themselves and do the research
because some people I guess train
without a personal trainer they just
kind of go and cane it at the gym maybe
you're absolutely right yeah yeah we we
don't take enough time to educate
ourselves I think we're led by the
latest fads and the you know that what
we read in the newspapers what we're
reading magazines we as an ocean need a
more rounded approach to fitness you
know there is a lot more to to exercise
than just resistance and cardio based
activities you know we take need to take
care of our bodies we need to take more
rounded approach flexibility for example
massage so really it that rounded
approach is that almost that prehab
approach to prevent injury Daniel is
there a danger that people are more
kamakazi because they think oh well
actually if hip replacements are being
offered to people so young and you know
they can last so many decades now that
you know it can be fixed if I get an
injury can be fixed so people being
reckless with their bodies I think one
phrase is quite key prevention is better
than cure if you can prevent something
from happening you're infinitely better
than trying to fix it once it's already
become a problem and that's as Neil said
it's eminently doable but people just
need to be aware seek a preventive
measure or seek sort of an appropriate
approach to exercise that is that is
better for the person long-term rather
than looking for a quick fix or quick
solution to sort of losing weight or or
to reaching that goal that they're
looking for progression and and sort of
so just a quite rounded sensible
approach to exercise is key Neil there
seems to be a plethora of kind of
challenges out there for ordinary folk
where they can go and you know run
through mud for a couple of miles and
you know kind of army training type
things and ordinary people are taking
them out people aren't necessarily that
fit and healthy do you think they
understand the training that's required
or do they perhaps turn up on the day
underprepared I
I think largely largely they turn up I'm
prepared and like we were suggesting
earlier on like Daniel was quite rightly
suggesting we don't know enough about
our bodies we don't we don't know what
position you know we're actually and
physically so to undertake something you
know like like one of them popular
challenges that are out there at the
moment it's a we don't understand how
what impact that load has on our body
and how much that we need to actually
prepare for that load for that
resistance yeah Daniel my producers just
whispering to mamaya she does three
classes gym classes in a row one after
another I actually my knee was hurting
this week so I don't know what I did
last week when I was doing the minimum
bit of exercise that I do and I just
carried on training through it actually
we don't necessarily know what to do
should you be doing class after class in
a row or is it just too much impact on
your body well as I mentioned so if
that's something you're used to in to
something you built up to over time
you've done necessary preparation work
the strength training as Neil says the
flexibility training and the necessary
sort of build up into that into that
amount of exercise and that's fine and I
personally run relatively long
triathlons I built up over a year to get
to those or distances and that would be
the advice I'd give anyone trying to get
into whether it's three classes of an
evening you start with one do that for
six seven eight weeks build up to 1 plus
a run and then maybe two classes just be
sensible in what you what are the
trigger points so if you do have aches
and pains and what point you actually
have to say I've got to stop now and
actually get this scene too or is it
just you know what month like I said my
knees hurting a little bit do I as you
go and see someone georgous it carry on
training through the pain barrier I'm
again sort of particularly nowadays on
on Facebook and social media you see
people sort of push themselves through
various crazy challenges so there's a
big ethos where you should push yourself
a pain barrier but frankly people know
what is roughly normal for their body
and what is normal post exercise and if
not you stick the education and advice
and if something feels abnormal
generally and particularly people to
come and see me in clinic people say
this just doesn't feel right and
going to get it investigated and I think
as soon as that sensation comes on as
soon as between you have that feeling
then that's when you should seek help
alright daniel boyd Neil Diamond great
to talk about money i'd like to say
you've inspired me to do more exercise
but i'm not sure you really have carry
on being lazy as usual thank you